[Music]
the Academy Award of Merit more commonly
known as the Oscar statuette has been
awarded by the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences since 1929 this statue
was designed by MGM art director Cedric
Gibbons and created in 3d form by
sculptor George Stanley the statuette is
of a knight holding a sword on top of a
reel of film each spoke in the film reel
represents the original five branches of
the Academy producers directors writers
actors and technicians the statue stands
at 13 and a half inches tall with a
diameter of five and one quarter inches
and weighs eight and a half pounds but
where do these beautiful gold statues
come from they are created here at RS
Owens in Chicago each year RS Owens
produces 50 to 60 of these handcrafted
statues for the Oscar ceremony the Oscar
first takes shape in the casting process
first the mold of the Oscar statue is
constructed
[Music]
then the 960 degree molten Britannia
metal is poured and in just moments the
metal solidifies
[Music]
the stem is cut and all rough seams are
sanded before moving on to the polishing
stage each statue is carefully hand
polished to a bright mirror finish
ensuring that all of Oscar's features
stay intact and then it's on to the
electroplating electroplating involves
the statue being hand dipped into for
electroplating metal solutions first the
Oscar is plated with copper to prevent
corrosion second it will be dipped into
a nickel solution to improve the
adhesive qualities of the surface silver
becomes the third layer creating a
bright shiny base for the final solution
the 24 karat gold meanwhile the base is
being spun from a raw brass material and
polished and plated with black nickel
once this base has taken shape a small
plate is affixed to identify the statue
as an official Academy Award
when Oscars plating is finished he
receives a unique identification number
and is ready for the final process oscar
is carefully mounted on the base and a
circular felt pad is placed on the
bottom then oscar is placed inside
custom packing material to ensure that
he arrives to the ceremony unharmed
there is one final touch before Oscar is
finished and that's the personal
engraved tag identifying the winner that
will have to wait until the Oscar
ceremony to find out whose name will be
on this Oscar
[Music]
you
[Music]